okay hi um
i'd like to
thank the organizers for
inviting me here and um
especially because it helped me stop
procrastinating and and do something
which was on my uh
mathematical to-do list for more than a
decade
so when when i got the invitation from
jaikumar i said well what'll i speak
about um
i have a result i'll mention here with
voita rodel from ten years ago
but then i remembered i also i always
wanted to prove becker's inequality the
primal version using entropy i said okay
so now i have a year to do it
and uh i'm glad to report that i
succeeded with
tons of time to spare i finished a week
ago so
so we're okay yeah i'm glad you didn't
invite me a week later then
i don't know what would have
talk
happened
there is
another talk tomorrow maybe
okay
about the riemann hypothesis so
yeah
yeah deadlines work that's uh okay so
this is a i took this picture the locals
may identify this cinema this is last
time i was here and uh
it's uh
an advertisement for my talk
um
okay so here's what i'm going to do
first i'll tell you a bit about the
inequality i i'm not going to assume
that you're familiar with it although
i'm sure many of you are
and then i'll mention this older result
with a riddle that we proved the dual
and the the new proof of the primal
version and although they're both
information theoretic i
i see absolutely no connection between
the two proofs
they prove dual results but results
which are equivalent but the proofs have
nothing to do with each other as far as
i can see
okay so
let's start with um
telling you why you should be interested
in this inequality so
i was too lazy to write this slide
myself i cut and pasted from a paper of
blaze and tan which i'll mention later
and they say let me read about what they
say first introduced into theoretical
computer science by the celebrated work
of kkl
the hypercontractive inequality has seen
utility in a surprisingly wide variety
of areas spanning distributed computing
random graphs case sets social choice
and approximate
inapproximability
learning theory metric spaces
statistical physics convex relation
hierarchies whatever that is etc
in almost every one of these results
there are no known alternate proofs that
do not require the use of hyper
contractivity
and part of the reason i wanted to
prove this inequality is to understand
it better because
i've used it a lot myself and
i i like getting
more friendly with uh
inequality before i use it so
um okay so here's a quick background
we're looking at functions on a minus
one once then
so
most basic function is you give me a
vector i return one of its coordinates
so they're n of those functions they're
monomials of degree one and if you
take a set of coordinates and multiply
the
multiply them and get the monomial of
degree whatever the size of
i is
and
you can take any subset of n you have
two then such monomials
and
the space of functions on
to the endpoints also has degree as
they mentioned two then so these
monomials span
all functions
on all real functions on the space
so
they form a basis for the space of
functions and in fact if you take the
uniform the uniform measure and the
standard inner product they're
they're orthonormal so
they all have expectation zero
expectation squared one and if you
take the product of two different one
two of the two different
monomials you'll get
another monomial from this family which
again will have expectation zero so if
you have any real function f you can
expand it as a polynomial and the the
coefficient of the
polynomial corresponding to coordinates
at i is the fourier transform at i
so this is
the unique expansion
and
okay now i want to tell you what this
operator
um that we're interested in what it is
so
first you can look at the two-point
space you have a function on two-point
space any such
function
can be written as ax plus b
and what the operator does to the
function
it leaves b
the constant part fixed and the part
that has expectation zero which is
orthogonal to the constant it shrinks by
an epsilon factor
so that's what it does to functions on
two point space
and if you take the tensor of the
two-point space n times then
the functions on the tensors of the
functions on the two-point space span
the functions on the due to the endpoint
space
and you can take the tangent of the
operator
and it works on functions on
on the n-dimensional space
now i'll i'll
tell you how this operator works in an
i'll repeat this in a slightly different
from a slightly different angle but i
wanted to say
to point out the tensor definition
because
most proofs of the inequality
go like this we prove the inequality on
the two-point space and then
the inequality tensorizes whatever that
means so you have to use something about
to use minkowski's
inequality when you
see that
you can keep the inequality when when
you tensorize
um but here's a different way of
defining the operator i'll just tell you
what its eigenfunctions are
so for any
of the one a degree one monomials it
just multiplies it by epsilon
and if you have a degree d d monomial
then it will multiplied by epsilon to
the d
so
these are the two then eigen functions
of the
of this operator and they have
these are the eigenvalues and you see it
it uh
it tends to
really
suppress or kill
high degree monomials and this this is
useful and it's relevant because
when you look at uh
at the function
the the high degree part of the function
is what's responsible for most of the um
influences and if you want to kill
so it's it's something that happens a
lot that you want to suppress the
high degree part of the function this is
what this operator does
and um
okay so and you extend it by linearity
to any function
operate on the function it hits each for
each monomial by epsilon to the degree
of that monomial
that's one way of defining the
operator here's a totally
unrelated way but it's the definition is
equivalent
you take
a vector x
and then you take a noisy version of x
so
y is a noisy version of x for every
coordinate
you can with probability epsilon keep it
fixed and with probability one minus
epsilon you flip a coin and tells you
whether you're going to reset it or not
so you just
y i
independently for each i you set it to
be
you choose it such that the expectation
of x i y is epsilon so y is a noisy
version of x
and then
let's say we'll call them an epsilon
correlated pair
and
here's a different definition of the
operator if i want to
see what t of f and now it's indexed by
epsilon what t of f
is at the point x
then i average the value of f on all
on all y's where the probability of
of each y is
the probability of that a noisy copy of
x will give me y
so in this definition you see that it
takes a function
and it replaces its average at its value
at a point by an average of the points
around it where points which are closer
get
more weight and points the further away
get less weight so when you see this
definition of the operator
it's pretty clear that it should smooth
out the function if the function has
a peak
then after you apply the operator you're
going to
get something smoother
and indeed this is um this is what
beckner's inequality which was proven by
bonomi and growth before bechner
this is what it states it states the
following
that um
take a function f
and i want to compare f
to t of if i want to say that if f is
smoother
well the two norm is always now epsilon
is some number less than one
so one plus epsilon squared is less than
two
i'm saying that if i take t of f and i
take a higher norm which puts more
emphasis on
on peaks
uh
it's not going to be more than what i'd
get if i take if with a smaller norm so
this is a way of saying that t of f is
smoother than f
the two norm of t of f is equivalent to
a smaller norm of f
is less than a smaller norm of f so
the operator smoothes out the function
and
as i mentioned before t kills the high
degrees
so this sort of
brings to mind the fact that perhaps the
low degree
polynomials are smoother than high
degree polynomials
and the dual version of this
inequality which is equivalent you just
need helder's inequality to go
from one of them to the other
says the following
so let's let's look at the function
whose fourier transform is
um
exactly
uh on level m or up to level m so we
have a degree m polynomial f and
now i'm going to uh compare the q norm
of f for some q greater than 2
with the two norm of f so the q norm of
f is larger because it gives more weight
to the
peaks but it's this tells you it's not
much larger it's smaller than something
to the m
times the two norm
and that something is square root of q
minus one
okay so this tells you that a
low degree polynomials the q norm is
larger than the two norm but not much
larger so it tells you that low degree
functions are
behave nicely
okay so let's now let me try to
say what
what we proved and how we proved it
so
with uh voita
back in 2001 we we
wrote a paper about the proof of the
dual version
and we could have said in the
introduction the following uh bonami and
others proved a similar result in the
70s however our result is more recent
and less general
so why why bother at all because well it
uses entropy so it gives a new way to
look at this
inequality and what i
the reason i wanted
to do this i think it it
when you compare the two different norms
it gives you some combinatorial
understanding of why
the four norm is comparable to the two
norms so what we proved
we we compared the four norm to the two
norm and it's uh
it's exponential in the degree
but the base of the exponent we got was
fourth root of 28 where um if you
remember
we should have gotten square root of
three
okay so
fourth root of 28 is more than square
root three
so this is this is weaker but
um what i said to myself then is that i
don't care about the constant or i
pretended that i didn't care about the
constant because
a
in all the applications i know no one
ever
and overall never says okay now we're
going to use kkl and the constant kkl is
3.5
usually people don't care about the
constants and second thing was that it
seemed to me that although we were being
sort of wasteful and i could see where
we were being wasteful
it seemed to me that this
method had its limits and there's no
chance of getting the best constant even
if we tried so
i didn't try too hard and then i was
quite astonished er oops
um a decade later to encounter this
paper by blazentan where they
not only for four but for every even
integer
they got they used entropy and they got
the precise
the best possible constant so it's
it was surprising to me that this method
is is that powerful that you can really
get the
constant then yeah
exactly
okay so let me say a few words about
what what i did with the vita
so
we have this
we have this function let's say it's
it's homogeneous of degree m so it's
only
a sum of monomial a linear combination
of monomials of degree m
and um
let's see what what is its two norms so
the two norm is just the expectation of
f squared you take f inner product with
itself
then x i and x j are orthogonal
so if
f hat i and f i j disappear and you
you're only left with the squares of the
fourier coefficients
now when you take the fourth norm what
happens when you multiply four of these
monomials well if there's some
coordinate that appears in
one out of the four monomials or three
out of the four monomials
then when you take the expectation
you're going to get the expectation of f
x i or of x i cubed which is
zero
so when does it not cancel
whenever
i take x i x j x k x l
uh
i count f at i f at j f at k f at l
precisely if every coordinate appears in
an even number
of these sets i j k and l and that's
just saying that their symmetric
difference is zero so
um
the four norm is the expectation of f
uh before and now you see why even
integers come in if i were trying to the
three norm is not the expectation of f
cubed it's expectation of
so
so i have to compare
this expression uh over
quadruples where
the the sum
the
z2 to the end sum is zero
with the sum of all the squares
so here's what we're going to do um
i'm
i'm going to fix some partition of my
ground set
so
uh
i'll call this a script i and i'm my
calligraphy is very weak so i'm just
going to use capital for script this is
this is going to be the i part the j
part and the k part and then that for if
i want i j k l the symmetric difference
b 0 that means that um
l has to be
this part so if i know i j
k and l i j and k then i know l so i'm
going to partition my ground set once
and
once and for all or
i'll partition it and then
um
i'll look at these sounds but i'll only
look at things which are consistent with
my partition so i'll only count f hat i
if the set i sits inside
the the big i and same with j k and l
and for quadruples i will i want the
whole thing to be consis consistent with
my partition so
i look at ijkl i look at the venn
diagram of those four
uh
sets and see is it consistent with the
partition i took if it is then i count
it if not then i don't
okay and now i
i'm going to prove that for a fixed
partition if i look at the
what corresponds to the four norman
it's actually smaller than what
corresponds to the two norm and um
i'm going to be happy
and then um and in order to do that i'm
going to use a fractional version of
shiro's lemma i'll tell you about
jerusalem in a second
and then um
so this is what natty told me that in
hungary they learn this in elementary
school
so maybe gabor can tell if it's true or
not that uh you you prove something for
the random case and then you show that
the general case is just like the random
so
if this is true for every partition we
take a random partition it will hold for
the random partition but when you do the
random partition
what you get here is going to
be
intimately related to the four norm and
what you get here is going to be
intimately related to the two norm
so
you you get what you want but you lose
some uh
some multiplicative constant so that's
why i was saying this
this can't give you the tight constant
what's the um what's the difference
between the the script eye and regular
eye
script eye where is there a script eye
oh on the board
so this was a partition of the ground
set
the top line it starts with a lit oh so
the the these are a
um subsets of my ground set
and the other
and these
so
um
oh okay the union of script i script js
script k
this should be script k and scriptdale
is all of my ground state i take my
ground set and i partition it into seven
parts
and these four parts are script i these
four parts are script j et cetera et
cetera okay does does that answer your
questions
so we're here
so now i'm looking at all quadruples i j
k l
which are consistent with script i
script j script k script l
it means that
the intersection of i and j lie in the
intersection of script in script j the
intersection of i and j
minus k so
i look at the venn diagram of i j k l it
also give me seven parts each part
lies within the corresponding part of
the
partition of the ground set
okay
and
the reason i'm going to need that is
because
i want it to be the case that if you
tell me what the union of i j k and l is
i can
reconstruct from that what i j and k and
l are so
if if i j k and l are a consistent with
my
partition of the ground set and you tell
me that their union
is this then i know what i j k and l are
this is i
this is j that's it okay so that
okay so
um
okay so
you have a deadline
yeah yeah
but
i have uh make sure so i i have what 10
minutes
yes
okay so
okay so what's shira's lemon fractional
sheriff and why is it related to this
um so here's shiro's lemma
um i have some
i have some ground set v
and
i have a family of subsets of v let's
call it e
and
i have f1 up to if our are subsets of v
so let's
start with the case where they're a
partition of v but
they don't necessarily have to be a
partition of v so let's say i have
f1 f2 and f3
then
for every
element
little e
inside big e
every set in my family it has
i can look at its projections at its
intersection with f1 let's call this
little e1 and intersection once f2 is
little e2 and the intersection one f3 is
little e3
and i can ask what do i see when i look
only through a window on f1 how many
different sets do i see how many
different intersections do i see let's
call the set of intersections that i see
e1
and
e2 is what i see when i look through
this window and e3 is what i see when i
look through this window
and obviously
um
the product of the three sizes here is
greater or equal than
the size of e
because there's an injection from
uh sets and e to the cartesian products
of the
uh
i associate every set with an e with a
triple
coming from
the first quarter from here second from
here and third from here so obviously
the size of e is less than the product
of these three
now what happens
let's you have some positive integer t
what happens if every one of these sets
every vertex every
element in my ground set is covered by
at least two of these sets
okay so
if um
if every element is covered by two of
these sets then then this is
this is overshooting and i get if every
element is covered by tv sets i get to
put a t here
okay that's shira's lemma shiraz lama
says that
if every element is covered by t of
these f's
then um
then you get to put a t here and
there's a very nice
well
the
shira's proof isn't isn't difficult but
jai kumar when he was a postdoc in
jerusalem he showed me
the book proof of this
it's it's very it has a very nice proof
and if you know the
the book proof
then you can also
prove the following
so this is a small variation on shira's
lemma what what happens now
is
the setting is the same as before but
every one of these eyes
gets a weight
so
for each eye i so i associate with it a
non-negative real weight
w
i
a v i
and the reason i put wi here e i
e i as a set that set could
once play the role of e1 and once play
the role of e2 it could happen that that
set is the intersection of one edge
with uh
f1 and of a different edge with f2
remember f1 and f2 overlap so
when i look at it as a projection of
something from
uh
the intersection with fi i give it a
certain weight wi
and then we just get a weighted version
of what we had before
instead of um
counting how many
sets i have in my family
i go over each set in my family
and i give it the product of the of the
weights of the produce of the
projections
okay so if all the weights were one then
this product would be one and i'd just
be counting
the number of sets in my family but here
for every set i i count it take the
product of the projections of the
weights
on the right hand side
instead of uh count instead of counting
the size of e i
i i go over the elements of e i and
uh for each one i look at the weight
raised to the t power
so we have
there is one weight function
no there's for each eye there's a weight
function wi
but i is ranging from what to what i is
ranging from one to r
it's it's the so for every set
of ei or is it wj
no i mean wi of vi or
no no so i look at e
and e has projections
e i is the intersection of e with f i so
i look at this i look at the edge in my
hyper graph i look at the set e then i
look at all its intersections each one
of them is endowed with a weight take
the product of those weights
okay
okay so how is this related to
uh
how is this related to um the inequality
we're trying to prove
so here's the fractional version of
sharer
and now this should look to you a little
bit like this
so let's see what we have here
the
my family of sets so now i for every i j
k and l which are consistent with my
partition
i look at their union
that
is e that's an that's an
uh set in my family and
the weights when i look at e i look at
the intersection of e with i
that's this here
this here is going to be
uh
e i so now i have e i e j e e k e l
instead of i going from one to n
i j k and l are alright
uh yeah instead of yeah instead of i
going from one to r now i just have i j
k now and and the weight i give is the
fourier coefficient i didn't say before
but we can assume that all the fourier
coefficients are are positive
because uh
um on this on the side it's supposed to
be bigger they appear with squares so
if they're negative
yeah okay so uh so the weights of the
projections are the fourier coefficients
and
uh
so the product of the weights associated
to the edge e are just the
the product of the four fourier
coefficients and why is t equal to two
well precisely because this is uh
this is
the symmetric difference of i j k and l
is zero
but the union is everything means that
every every element is covered either
two or four times so it's covered at
least two times
so i use the
the lemon with t equals to two
and i get that uh
and that's
that was what we needed for fixed
partition and then for the general case
i do it with the random partition
okay let me so that's
that's all i wanted to say about um
the stuff with voita
let me say just a few words about
the the new proof
so now
um
i i want to i want to prove
the primal version now
and there are two two
cases a simple case is when
the
the function that appears is a boolean
function and
the more general cases when it's not
necessarily boolean
and also i want to instead of looking at
one function i'm looking at a two
function version of this inequality so
this is
supposedly
seemingly it's stronger i mean by taking
two functions to be equal you
immediately get the inequality for one
function but it's not really stronger
it's equivalent so let's see what
what's the boolean case i have two sets
x
the script x and script y
and i take x and y to be epsilon
correlated vectors
and on one side of the inequality i ask
what's the probability that
that
capital x falls in script x and capital
y falls in script y that both these
things happen
and on the right hand side i just
i look at the measure of script x and
measure script y
but uh
i have to give it some advantage the
fact that these are correlated
means that i can make the left hand side
slightly bigger than what you'd expect
but if i raise this to the power of 1
over one plus epsilon then i'm making
this side bigger also and this tells you
that this size is bit is bigger but not
too much bigger
and trust me this is exactly it's it's
exactly the boolean case of beckner's
inequality
and and then of course you can say if
it's not boolean then i want the same
thing for for functions f and g
and uh
why would this have anything to do with
information theory well the thing is
that i'm i'm taking x randomly and why
randomly what i'm going to do
what i'm not going to do in this talk
but what i do in the paper is i i reveal
the bits of x and y one by one
and i ask how much information do i gain
from
from revealing these uh
these bits and i compare it to how much
information i'd get if i was just
looking at each one of them separately
so if i take the log of of both sides
i'm on one side i'm going to get the
entropy of something on the other side
i'm going to get the entropy of
something else
and then if i use the chain rule then i
just go bit by bit
and
when i decided to do this i said two
things could happen one thing could
happen that could happen is that on
average
the bits on corresponding left side will
have less information on the bits
on the right side
and if that's just on average and it
depends on what you've seen before then
then all is lost and this proof won't
work
but happily what happens is that no
matter what you've seen up till now
every single
coordinate that you reveal
the
uh irregardless of what you've seen up
till now
the the bits corresponding to the
left-hand side
carry uh no more information than
what they're supposed to carry
and
and uh and proof goes through so instead
of doing it by induction on the
dimension this is you're just saying
that for each coordinate you get some
contribution and on every single
coordinate the contribution to the
right-hand side is greater than the
left-hand side
and and for the non-boolean case
um
somehow i thought would be more
difficult but actually it's
you take the same proof and add two more
lines so you you just slightly
alter the definition of the random
variable whose entropy is the left-hand
side
you add just uh
one more coordinate
telling you
once you know x uh
you're somewhere between
uh one and f of x and another coordinate
tells you somewhere between one and g of
y and
you can assume that these are positive
integers i won't say y right now and and
then just by adding two more lines to
the proof you go from the boolean case
to the
non-boolean case and um
let me just go through the proof quickly
so you see
if you see any errors tell me because um
and yeah and then okay you have to take
of course this case into account
and uh
yeah and then
and then you're done
yes showing us
sure yeah um
i'll show you but you really don't need
any ingenuity for it it sort of it jumps
out at you because
this is what we want to prove
you take the log of both sides
and
trust me this is just a straightforward
you write out this expression what it
means
each point x gets weight 2 to the n and
and you weight it by
if x and y agree on a coordinate you get
a
an ups
grade one plus epsilon if they disagree
you get a downgrade 1 minus epsilon so
this is what you have to prove
and then as usual in entropy you want
everything to be integers so you look
for two integers s and r r and s such
that
their
ratio is 1 plus epsilon over 2 and 1
minus epsilon over 2.
and then you get this
and now
you can tell me
what the
random variable is it's it's going to be
very clear
i
i look
i define
for every coordinate i
i
i define four sets
what these are just
auxiliary sets of size r r s and s
well i'm thinking
x i and y i can be 0 0 1 1
and then
what what does my uh
i have a random variable z
x y
and i take it uniform on all
on all um
vectors such that
x belongs to x y belongs to y
and for every i
z i
so if if x i is equal to one and y i
is equal to zero
then i have to take z i from
from here
okay
and and this just tells you that
conditioned on the this being
x i being one in y being zero it's going
to have entropy log s
okay it's uniform on a set of size s
and
and so that tells you what what z should
look like
and um
and then and then okay then you have to
see what it means
bit by bit and eventually it comes down
to a calculus question
a function you have
it's going to boil down to a calculus
question
where you have
a distribution on four points
and
what you have to show that some function
is non-negative so you see
you look at the entropy of x you look at
the entropy of y you look at the joint
entropy
you have some price to pay where
uh
every time x is equal to y and you have
to
show that this is non-negative
and
if you just had to show this was
non-negative it would be quite difficult
but
you know what the minimum
you you know what you hope the minimum
is when
when both x and y are are uniform on the
whole space then you get equality
so that tells you what you expect to be
the minimum and then you just have to
show that that's the unique minimum
and you use lagrange multipliers and you
find conditions for the minimum and it
turns out that this is the unique
minimum
yes
one
is a very special norm because the
conjugates are equal how is it one plus
epsilon is a very special norm right
because the conjugates are equal for one
foreign
on both the powers right that's because
one perception is very special because
the conjugate one perception and the
corresponding queue for royal
i didn't try but i'm
i'm optimistic that you could try to do
the proof and it would work also for
pq
it's very simple so i mean for one how
does one normal growth go to the other
nominees
so
what you're saying is this this could
work for
a slightly more general statement and
maybe it does i don't know i didn't
check it
you